[Música]
rusia acusa a ucrania de bloquear el
ingreso del organismo internacional de
la energía atómica a sap orilla para
revisar cómo quedó la planta de nuclear
más grande de europa luego de los
bombardeos en los que las partes se
culpan mutuamente quien responde que
esto es un total despropósito y que
quiere que el organismo vaya a la
central
'israel reabre parcialmente de los
accesos a la franja de gaza una semana
después de habernos bloqueado el ingreso
de combustible permitió que se
reactivará la planta de energía
esto ocurre horas después de que los
israelíes y la jihad islámica palestina
saltarán un cese del fuego luego de tres
días de bombarderos
y un tercer tanque de combustible se
incendió en la provincia cubana de
matanzas el juego que comenzó el viernes
se propagó en la noche del domingo y hoy
la presidencia del país afirma que la
infraestructura colapsó
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos con noticias de
la guerra en ucrania moscú y kiev se
acusan mutuamente de no permitir el
ingreso del organismo internacional de
la energía atómica a sap orilla esto
para revisar cómo quedó la planta
nuclear más grande de europa después de
los bombardeos de este fin de semana
rusia afirma que quiere que el oiea
visite la central que está bajo su poder
pero que los ucranianos lo bloquean el
embajador de ucrania ante el organismo
rechazó las alegaciones diciendo que son
un total despropósito las versiones
encontradas también han sido sobre
quienes están atacando la planta atómica
estás imágenes publicadas por el
ministerio de defensa ruso muestran los
cráteres de los proyectiles y los
escombros alrededor de la central
nuclear de sapo l'illa después de que el
sitio fuera atacado durante el fin de
semana
rusia y ucrania se han responsabilizado
mutuamente por el bombardeo la
instalación las autoridades respaldadas
por moscú alegan que las fuerzas
ucranianas atacaron el lugar con un
lanzacohetes múltiple dañando las líneas
eléctricas y una tubería de agua kiev
por su parte dice que los bombardeos
rusos dañaron tres sensores de radiación
e hirieron a un empleado de la planta el
presidente de ucrania pidió a la
comunidad internacional que responda con
sanciones al sector nuclear ruso de
manera que ninguna nación del mundo
puede sentirse segura cuando un estado
terrorista es para contra una central
nuclear
dios no lo quiera si ocurre algo
irreparable nadie detendrá el viento que
propagar a la contaminación radioactiva
sandro
el mayor complejo de energía nuclear de
europa está bajo control ruso desde
marzo pero sigue siendo operado por
técnicos ucranianos el organismo
internacional de energía atómica afirma
que los ataques a la central ponen de
manifiesto un riesgo muy real de
catástrofe nuclear el secretario general
de la onu antonio guterres pide a ese
organismo que estabilice la situación en
sap orilla en cualquier ataque a una
central nuclear es algo suicida
espero que la oea pueda tener acceso a
la planta y ejercer las competencias que
le corresponden tras la compañía de
energía nuclear de ucrania acusa a rusia
de intentar cortar la energía de la
planta que proporciona al país el 20 por
ciento de su electricidad
una de las noticias positivas de la
guerra es que hoy se abrió el tercer
puerto por el que ucrania exportar a sus
granos se trataba del muelle de pib de
angie en la región de do deza hasta
ahora 12 barcos han sido autorizados en
el acuerdo entre los ucranianos y los
rusos y este lunes un buque se convirtió
en él en llegar a su destino final al
arribar al puerto turco de lérins en el
reporte desde juan pablo lo cómico
la primera carga de cereales ucranianos
llegó a su lugar de destino tres días de
haber zarpado el transportador de granos
por la net arribó al norte de turquía
con 12.000 toneladas de maíz
convirtiéndose en la primera entrega
efectiva desde que el mes pasado se
firmó el acuerdo que busca desbloquear
las más de 20 millones de toneladas de
cereales que se acumularon en los
puertos de ucrania desde la invasión
rusa este lunes también se armaron otros
dos barcos desde puertos de la región de
odessa con destino a italia y turquía
con 11 mil toneladas de soja y más de 48
mil toneladas de maíz en una ruta por el
mar negro que el capitán de uno de los
barcos ha calificado como desafiante y
peligrosa
hubo 17 tramos hasta la llegada a
estambul de corto medio y largo alcance
estas serán por supuesto áreas
peligrosas corredores que habían sido
despejados desminados dejamos zonas de
riesgo a medida que nos acercábamos a
las aguas territoriales romanas
en un revés para toda la operación de
entrega de alimentos este lunes el
comprador libanés rechazó el cargamento
del barco razón y que salió desde
ucrania el primero de agosto debido al
retraso en la entrega de la mercancía
según la embajada ucraniana en beirut el
vendedor ahora busca un nuevo interesado
en la compra de grano dentro o fuera del
líbano mientras que la administración
militar de odessa dio a conocer el
inicio del funcionamiento del tercer
gran puerto de la región repiten ya
lo que ucrania está haciendo hoy es
salvar al mundo del hambre entonces
vemos como hoy el enemigo la federación
rusa cumple los acuerdos alcanzados con
turquía y la onu es decir con la
organización en los países grandes
la guerra provocó una crisis alimentaria
que afectó sobre todo a países de
oriente medio y áfrica en tiempos de paz
ucrania exportaba hasta 6 millones de
toneladas de cereales al mes en las
costas del mar negro y el mar de azov
luego de una semana de bloqueos por
parte de israel las autoridades de este
país comenzaron a reabrir parcialmente
los cruces hacia la franja de gaza los
israelíes permiten por ahora únicamente
los suministros de necesidades
humanitaria y así llegaron los primeros
camiones de combustibles con los que se
reinició la única planta de energética
del enclave esto es un efecto de la
tregua que pactaron israel y la yihad
islámica palestina del domingo con la
mediación de egipto según el ministerio
de sanidad palestino el enfrentamiento
de tres días dejó 44 fallecidos
incluidos 15 niños
es el primer día de tregua después de
tres días de hostilidades la jihad
islámica palestina e israel cesaron sus
ataques en una negociación mediada por
egipto según el ejército israelí el
último ataque se registró media hora
antes de la medianoche del domingo
naciones unidas- y egipto pidieron
respetar el alto el fuego pero el grupo
yihadista aseguró que se reserva el
derecho a responder cualquier nueva
agresión la a-2 el enemigo pretendía
acabar con la yihad islámica pero no lo
hicimos por el contrario logramos algo y
forzamos las condiciones por las que
comenzamos la batalla con el enemigo
israel se comprometió a liberar a
nuestros prisioneros y facilitan
con un regreso lento a la normalidad los
habitantes en casa agradecieron por un
amanecer sin bombardeos mientras entre
escombros se contabiliza el saldo de
muertos y heridos que dejó el
enfrentamiento más mortífero desde la
guerra de 11 días el año pasado
recibimos la noticia el alto el fuego
con alegría y felicidad volvimos a
nuestro trabajo no queríamos más
derramamiento de sangre y gracias a
dios' volvimos a nuestro trabajo y
abrimos las puertas de nuestras tiendas
yo haga la frontera entre israel y la
franja de gaza está nuevamente abierta
tras un cierre de casi una semana que
dejó la única central eléctrica del
enclave palestino sin suministros de
combustible
30 camiones en este momento es una
cantidad suficiente y en los próximos
días esperamos aproximadamente el mismo
número de vehículos para llenar el vacío
el conflicto inició con un ataque
preventivo de israel en el que murieron
los principales líderes de la yihad
islámica considerados terroristas por la
nación judía eeuu y la unión europea en
la última semana 40 miembros del grupo
islamista han sido detenidos por las
fuerzas israelí en cisjordania
hablemos ahora de américa en cuba-
aumentan los incendios en el
almacenamiento de combustible en la
provincia de matanzas hoy el tercero de
ocho tanques de petróleo colapsó según
la presidencia cubana el viernes un rayo
cayó en una de las instalaciones y esto
provocó el incendio inicial que luego
pasó a un segundo depósito y en la noche
del domingo el fuego rodeó el tercer
tanque aunque las autoridades intentaron
mantenerlo frío con el agua del mar
finalmente las llamas llegaron hasta
allí el accidente ha dejado un muerto y
125 heridos de los cuales 24 siguen
hospitalizados escuchemos amario sabines
el gobernador de matanzas ahora un poco
más de claridad vamos a explicar que
efectivamente el riesgo que habíamos
anunciado
ocurrió en el tanque
el incendio que había en el segundo
tanque comprometido entonces el que es
el tanque que ahora está incendiado de
la manera que se había visto
anteriormente funcionando como un un
pebetero lente corporal como un show es
la situación que había bases muy compre
tres tanques encendidos que además
vuelvo este combustible en el 1
funcionó entonces también como otra
bomba que está ahí en de grandes
dimensiones y el presidente de colombia
gustavo petro dio inicio a su mandato
con una multitudinaria toma de posesión
tras el final del periodo presidencial
del derechista iván duque petro presentó
las bases de lo que será su gobierno
enfocado en la búsqueda de la paz total
la igualdad y la defensa del medio
ambiente marta moya tiene los detalles
y prometo al pueblo
cumplir fielmente
y las leyes de colombia
el centro de bogotá se vistió de gala
para recibir a su nuevo equipo de
gobierno gustavo petro y francia-
márquez la vicepresidenta juramentaron
el cargo en una plaza de bolívar
abarrotada donde se congregaron miles de
sus fieles y personalidades políticas y
diplomáticas en su primer discurso como
presidente petro hizo alusión a su
compromiso más firme y decidido la paz
la paz es el sentido de mi vida es la
esperanza de colombia no podemos
fallarle a la sociedad colombiana los
muertos se lo merecen los vivos lo
necesitan la vida debe ser la base de la
paz una vida justa y segura una vida
para vivir sabroso para vivir feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sean
nuestra identidad además el mandatario
mencionó asimismo su decálogo de
gobierno con un énfasis en la igualdad
con la creación de un ministerio
dedicado a ello que encabezará francia
márquez la lucha férrea contra la
corrupción o la defensa de la
biodiversidad y el medio ambiente sin
embargo la búsqueda de la llamada paz
total ocupó gran parte de su discurso y
se comprometió a seguir las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad para la implementación real y
efectiva de los acuerdos de paz tenemos
que terminar de una vez y para siempre
con seis décadas de violencia y
conflicto armado
yo diría con dos siglos de guerra
permanente la guerra eterna la guerra
perpetua de colombia
se puede
cumpliremos el acuerdo de paz por
delante cuatro años donde las
negociaciones y las políticas de
sometimiento con los grupos armados
ilegales la reforma tributaria o la
lucha contra la emergencia climática
serán asimismo grandes retos a llevar a
cabo por el primer presidente de
izquierda en la historia de colombia
los demócratas estadounidenses aprobaron
en el congreso un proyecto de ley con
varios objetivos algunos de ellos son
invertir 64 mil millones de dólares en
salud y reducir paulatinamente el precio
de ciertos medicamentos también plantea
combatir la crisis climática con casi
370 mil millones para reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en un 40% antes de 2030
una victoria para la administración byd
en el senado de los eeuu aprobó un
paquete de 430 mil millones de dólares
para combatir el cambio climático y
reducir el precio de los medicamentos
entre otros objetivos con un congreso
dividido el proyecto de ley pasó gracias
a la aprobación de la vicepresidenta del
país y presidenta del senado los votos
positivos son 50 los negativos son 50 el
senado está dividido en partes iguales
la vicepresidenta vota afirmativamente y
se aprueba el proyecto de ley en su
forma en la nada
para los demócratas este logro
representa un punto a favor para las
elecciones de medio término del 8 de
noviembre se espera que el viernes se
vote en la cámara de representantes para
que inmediatamente pase al despacho de
joe biden para su firma el mandatario no
tardó en reaccionar hoy los demócratas
del senado votaron para reducir el costo
de los medicamentos recetados el seguro
de la salud y la energía al tiempo que
reducen el déficit y hacen que las
corporaciones más ricas paguen su parte
justa el líder de la minoría republicana
mitch mcconnell criticó el proyecto los
demócratas han demostrado una y otra vez
que simplemente no les importan las
prioridades de la familia de clase media
sólo el 18 por ciento de los
estadounidenses están contentos con esta
economía dirigida por demócratas la
legislación ayudará a eeuu a cumplir su
promesa de reducir a la mitad la emisión
de gases de efecto invernadero para el
2030 y reducirá los costos de los
medicamentos para el gobierno los
empleadores y los pacientes
comenzó en la sura la ceremonia
religiosa más importante de los
musulmanes chiitas en ella conmemora la
muerte del imán husein el nieto de
mahoma hace más de 1300 años en irán los
creyentes asistieron a un masivo ritual
de luto las personas se golpeaban el
pecho y los hombros con las manos o con
cadenas para expresar el dolor de la
muerte de husein
también hubo flagelaciones públicas
masivas en afganistán donde los chiítas
salieron a pesar de que el estado
islámico atacó a una fracción de estos
musulmanes la semana pasada y en irak la
conmemoración no se hizo en lugares
religiosos como es usual sino en la zona
verde de bagdad tomada por manifestantes
hussein fue asesinado junto con 72
amigos y familiares en la batalla de
kárbala en el actual irak
así despedimos las noticias los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
nosotros para más actualidad
internacional
[Música]